we have um Pi AP and
um uh data science fellow at um CVS and
then we have GRE a senior machine
learning engineer at CVS and in this
talk uh we're going to have talk about L
ml highs
and thank you everybody um my name is pi
this is brain as mentioned I'm an ABP um
of the ml platform and data science
fellow and Bin is a senior machine
learning engineer on the machine
learning platform
team so wanted to get to know a little
bit about the crowd so who here works
with python this is a python conference
so presumably everybody in the house
okay data scientists or machine learning
Engineers keep your hands
up model
developers okay who who deploys models
to
production okay and who thinks that
deploying models to production is
Trivial get
[Music]
out all right um so postmodel
development what do we really care about
um developing models is all well and
good I'm in my notebook I'm having fun
I'm importing libraries I'm playing
around with different things exploring
data I've now developed a model and I
presumably developed this model for a
reason to solve some business problem to
hit some evaluation metric and now I
need to uh I've satisfied those criteria
and I need to move something to
production what do I do now now you have
to start thinking about these second
world problems problems like
orchestration problems like my AI
infrastructure problems like MLS and
these are the these are the non-trivial
aspects um typically we look for char
characteristics like reliability and
scalability and maintainability when
we're thinking about distributed systems
when we're thinking about machine
learning Ops we'll often talk about uh
reproducibility or explainability
guarantees so we're in the United States
over in Europe right now they are U
companies that are doing machine
learning and artificial intelligence are
subject to regulation and uh if you're
reading the the winds right that is
going to change in the United States uh
presuma blade pretty pretty soon so it
proves us as practitioners to be well in
front of of that um and along the way
you know we should be uh developing good
good Reliable Software uh to the best of
our ability as well so bearing all of
that in mind uh has anybody ever seen
this picture before it's a crazy one
right first Mark Capital they have um
they do this inventory of all the tools
in the ecosystem system every year and
the the long story short here is that
the ecosystem is crazy crowded right
there are so many different solutions
for platforming and pipelining and you
name it here I just blew up a couple
boxes for uh like the mlops solutions
the AI infra and orchestration solutions
but we're not necessarily wanting for
optionality at this point uh but the
question is is do any of these things
really satisfy you know all of those
needs really
well so building from there a little bit
remember when we were we have our data
scientist haton and we're developing the
model in a notebook like most of us do
and then you get to that point where
it's good enough and you want to move it
to production well what next right we
can talk about uh refactoring your code
we can talk about learning a a workflow
plat platform we can talk about dsls yes
there are ways obviously but it Bears
asking the question could that be easier
is that time well spent uh for a data
scientist to to learn all of those
things now there are some really
promising projects that that I
particularly excited about in this area
uh notably uh linei and plumer and they
kind of they're seeking to to address
that problem of give me a notebook and
will give you a pipeline or parts of a
pipeline right back out texor flow is a
little bit of of an oddball here but
tensorflow is just such a massive
library that not only do they have Ting
architecture you can build all sorts of
simple machine learning models complex
machine learning models but you also
have tensorflow extended the ability to
express uh kind of pipelines or or
directed graphs of tasks in uh tensor
flow as well so if we agree that this is
a problem or an unsolved problem in the
industry as practitioners going from
notebook to hardened production
pipelines let's consider the
following
so why refactor if we don't have to
refactor like nobody would just refactor
for the sake of refactoring sometimes
you do it because you have to um but
typically refactoring happens when we
have a handoff so my team hands off to
another team
and what happens just like in
kindergarten when you're playing a game
of telephone with your friends so I
whisper something to someone and they
whisper it to somebody else and so on
and so forth ultimately at the end of
that chain something gets Lost in
Translation right we we lose some of the
Fidelity along the way um also as
developers and Engineers were're taught
dry do not repeat yourself so I I think
we can all get behind the idea that
refactoring should be avoided if
possible so from there um I know this
this meme was already used but kind of a
different one so the boss is asking uh
all the data scientists how will we
translate our models into pipelines and
somebody says yl and then somebody says
Jason and then somebody says uh let's
actually learn to use the workflow plat
platform well and uh and out the window
here she
goes um for for those of you that can't
see the slides or just listening to the
audio uh or something like that you know
there's this fictitious quote that I
thought about you know I studied math
and you know programming for for six
years in college and now I'm just
sitting there writing Json and you know
gamble files uh key value files all day
long and that's that's a terrible
existence right that's not something
that any of us like enjoy doing or or
aspire to do
so the third thing that I want you to
keep in mind here um for to consider
together is that locality matters and
that the developer experience and
ergonomics matter um there's this idea
of context switching and we can debate
whether or not multitasking and context
switching even works or um is effective
um but we all do it to some extent on on
our datto day um one one study suggested
that we spend about almost 10% of our
day context switching you know I'm
working in my IDE I jump to this tab in
the browser I jump over here I jump to
my second desktop where I'm running my
VM and over here and ultimately that's
not great you can't really really focus
as much when you're jumping from system
to system or um or context to context so
to tie that back to a data science
workflow you know I'm developing a model
in my notebook and then I say oh this
model is great let's uh move it to
production so maybe I convert it to a
bunch of python files I commit them to
GitHub maybe I pull them down my local
IDE and I start modularizing the code or
I start you know incorporating some of
the code into a workflow platform
turning it into a airflow pipeline or
something like that um but that's a lot
even even that involves a couple
different layers of context switching
and we've all just come to accept that
as status quo so the question is is can
we do better should we do better or
aspire to do better for some of the data
scientists that want to avoid
refactoring don't want to live in config
purgatory and um you know have a have a
bad reaction to all the context
switching enter stage left uh the
library textual um not sure is anybody
familiar with this with this Library
textual yeah it's it's pretty pretty
cool stuff
uh it came out after after Rich did uh
but you can develop these terminal user
interfaces that can run right your
terminal and you can also actually use a
textu to develop uh little like web
applications that run your browser as
well so we wanted to see what was
possible um with texal um to see if we
could take it and use it to solve some
of those problems um you know again
avoiding refactoring avoiding you know
living in in config files and
emphasizing low locality and ergonomics
um so we tried this we did this and U
currently we have this terminal user
interface um as part of the conduit
package that will um essentially be used
to configure your machine learning
pipelines and Vine will now uh well in a
moment sorry I forgot I one more slide
here um so with conduit there are these
five easy steps first we install the
package then we initialize the repo
templating from the command line and we
can copy and paste um your machine
learning code without refactoring it
into some of these templated files and
then you uh will go ahead and configure
your pipeline in the Tui and deploy it
so with uh deploying these models to to
production you know with this data scien
a profession that didn't exist 20 years
ago really there's just such a wide
range you have you know folks that
studied social science in college and U
maybe dabbled in a little r scripting
and then you have other folks that uh
learn to program when they're 8 years
old and have a PhD in computer science
and there's a lot in between um as a
data scientist who loves program um I
care most about solving problems and
creating impact um so time to Value
getting my models into production having
them touch lives or inform decisions
it's what's most important to me so the
the fact that a tool like this or other
tools if you at the the metaflow uh talk
earlier can help alleviate some of that
pain um the pain of orchestration
worrying about AI infra and uh ensuring
that you're following some semblance of
mlops best practices is pretty powerful
um and you know I think anybody who
who's been at this for a while we want
to avoid the refactoring we don't want
to be robots uh just working on Yo files
all day and uh to the extent that we can
keep things local and um somewhat
ergonomic is in our our Collective best
interest so what's what's next for
conduit um we want to continuing
continue adding components to the
component Library um so there are more
sophisticated patterns you know when you
think about uh self-healing systems or
models that can retrain themselves you
know my features drifted my labels
drifted okay I'm going to go and grab a
more recent window of data and just
retrain my models readily achievable
things right additional components
supporting different Frameworks uh like
like rine mentioned before um we haven't
gone really really deep into textual but
the the terminal use us interface can be
a lot more beautiful it can be a lot
more Dynamic um we just wanted to play
with this idea a little bit uh for for
some of the reasons mentioned before um
handling more more complicated or more
sophisticated pipeline assembly of
course um and you know the the Hot Topic
llm Ops I don't want to touch it right
now because I still think we're figuring
out exactly what that means but when the
time is right when some of those
patterns crystallize and the dust
settles I think think that's uh that's
the next area to look at you know
presumably our our scientists will want
to deploy um you know LM pipelines or
agent Frameworks as well in the future
so with that just want to thank all of
you for attending today and happy to
take any questions that you may
[Applause]
have
the boiler plate code that you generate
um are you guys planing to like into
like a library or
something or is it import that the
boiler plate code get created the
components are part of the conduit
library and then it draws from you know
those components to assemble them into a
pipeline based on the inputs that we
collecting through the 2E so you know
it's a model that's conducive to
interner sourcing or open sourcing
because you can bring your component you
can bring another component and um that
collection just builds and builds and
builds we also you know want to reuse
each other's components um just like we
may want to reuse a model or reuse a
pipeline so like that kind of
composability aspect and I think it
encourages the right type of
collaboration among teams avoid
recreating the wheel let collectively
build a better wheel
together
how use it do you have to Onex once
you're on vertex how how do you go about
using it yeah you want to take that one
sorry can you repeat that question like
you need to be on vertex to use conduit
uh yes currently you need to be on
Vortex because I mean technically the
package is a python package it's in Dono
right now but once we open sources you
can download it anywhere you want
however it generates Vortex AI bys right
and it's kind of going to be deployed
Onex so you need to and how
generalizable is that I guess that's
question like yeah is it generalized or
cross platforms yeah absolutely actually
technically we make Cube flow pipelines
right and as long as your platform
supports deploying Cube flow pipelines
then that's going to work yeah it's like
the idea in the abstract can work on top
of anything right now we focus on um you
know Cube flow pipelines because we're
working in GC on vertex
AI um but yeah it could be extended to
orgo CBE flow is kind of just like a
nice DSL on top of Argo anyway right or
you know uh airf flow if you're so
inclined I think I personally like cup a
lot I think it's future proof to the
extent that things can be future proof
within our industry like for at least
let's say like 5 years this idea that
like different tasks within my dag can
have have their own hardware and
software is like really powerful um so
you know if we just think about like an
NLP pipeline where you're like
tokenizing some things maybe you just
need some CPUs but then you need to do
some transfer learning I want gpus so um
we started with Cube flow and you know
um we'll probably take that a little bit
further and maybe upon open sourcing
would would love to see like how others
um would like to use it in other
workflow platform forms that they'd like
to
support y um you talked about the bat
prediction pipelines it's kind of
offline I was curious about um whether
you have support for the online uh
prediction or real time learning
model yeah I can do that U thank you for
your question yeah um as you saw in the
training pipeline the last part part of
that pipeline is deploying that model to
an endpoint uh and that endpoint is
scalable uh and queriable for your time
predictions um the cool thing about it
is like you can specify the hardware the
minimum hardware for that endpoint but
then it also owners scills to handle
whatever your request uh request size or
uh traffic might be so end the point is
kind of a low lency solution yes it's a
low latency solution around uh our Des
reveal like 300
milliseconds you can see which is I
think the
industry and that's one of the nice
these of vertex for example that they'll
scaffold those you know your um they'll
scaffold your prediction end points you
don't have to like go in there and roll
your own fast API or flask apps um and
that's nice right we've all done it like
have I done it well probably not like
maybe like a B minus or B stent student
like if I had to roll my own um rest API
so I think that's one particular nicity
of of what vertex brings to the table
follow question on that then where do
you define like what what end points you
want like you have your predict you have
your maybe like pre-processing stuff is
it all just rolled up in one yeah so I I
can explain more basically these end
points and batch predictions all spin up
like a server and there's a server. file
in the back end that we create it right
and that does the predict function now
if you have the SK learn API they have
standard predict predict proba and be
called both of them when they're
available uh but if you have and and our
stance is to roll up the pre-processing
in the pipeline do uh in in the Escalon
pipeline so in the model object as long
as you do all the pre-processing and
then youer to that Epi the server is
going to work out of the box however it
is customizable because if you use
conduit uh we present all the code uh
and it's like editable by you so if you
want to have some like custom
functionality and you want to change you
know the output of the predict function
is you can go in change that and that's
going to apply to um the Endo you're
going to get back the the type that you
want one more question yes like is there
way toate multiple projects like so I
noticed that because you create like
this repository um and is there a way to
have like a connective tissue between
repositories or they like isolated
SE right now the it's kind of like one
pipeline per repo sort of thing and that
has more to do with kind of our
Downstream cicd but there
wouldn't there wouldn't be any reason
why you couldn't have multiple pipelines
or pipelines talking to one another like
for example at the end of one of your
prediction pipelines or after you make
predictions if you want to like put a
message on Pub sub or something and then
somewhere Downstream there's a listener
waiting for that message or a cloud
function to do something with it um that
would be one way to sort of interconnect
things if you're leaning into like gcp
native stuff but um you know a lot of
like cus functions will allow you to
have that connective tissue um does that
answer your question oh yeah
perfect okay so there's a model logging
um feature to it
I didn't I don't remember if you mention
like how do you L your data how to
version your models oh yeah that that's
a great point so basically the um the
way the pipeline works is it's anchored
on the model name so if you run this
pipeline again through 28 with the same
model name and it passes the evaluation
metric it's going to up verion your
model so in model registry I can go show
you if you want um each model can have
multiple versions uh and you can do
traffic splitting between them as well
um so there going to be version one
version two version three currently the
latest version becomes the default
version and all the traffic goes to that
um but later when we once we get into
experimentation or EV testing we can
split the traffic between the models and
then on the logging front too that's
another area where we're kind of just
leaning into vertex AI they have all
sorts of metadata capture along the way
kind of analogous to what you get out of
like an ml flow for example um
and you know all all the logging that
comes with it
so if you were using a different a
different framework or kind of a
different stack maybe you know you need
to emphasize that more explicitly uh but
with RC PL pipelines using some of the
vertex Services it's kind of nicely
taken care of for
you all right I love this second row
here yeah lots of great questions all
right well I want to thank you again for
for listening if you have any questions
we'll stick around but really appreciate
it thank
[Applause]
you